another American has been detained in
North Korea raising the number of US
citizens held there too for North Korea
arrested Kim Hawk song on Saturday for
unspecified hostile acts he is a second
American professor to be arrested in the
last month Adriana Diaz is in Seoul
South Korea with the latest on this
string of detentions Adriana good
morning good morning at this point
little is known about Kim Hawk song or
why he was arrested Pyongyang University
of Science and Technology confirmed his
detention he was doing agricultural
development work there this comes just
two weeks after North Korea detained his
colleague Kim song duck also known as
Tony Kim for hostile criminal acts as he
was trying to leave the country these
latest arrests come amid heightened
tensions between the u.s. and North
Korea as the North continues to test
ballistic missiles and the US has beefed
up its military presence in the region
as a deterrent to other Americans are
also known to be in custody last year
university of virginia student otto
warmbier was sentenced to 15 years of
hard labor after he allegedly stole a
propaganda poster and american kim dome
tull is also serving 10 years for
alleged espionage the US State
Department says it is aware of this
weekend's detention and is working with
the Swedish embassy in North Korea
because the u.s. has no diplomatic ties
with the north for the release of all
the American prisoners there Charlie
Adriana Diaz in South Korea thanks